this steak isn't actually steak
it's made of beetroot seaweed pea
protein and algae and it's fresh off the
printer
just outside Barcelona in the catalonian
Farmland you'll find the meatest of
restaurants
El centuary is renowned for its
extensive range of exotic meats wagyu
crocodile zebra kangaroo and now 3D
printed vegan steaks cutlets and fillets
we only have a name in common and
because it's called Giuseppe catalanim
Giuseppe in Italian but the rest we come
from a different world is a meat lover
I'm trying to solve the meat issue right
and find an alternative to that
foreign
as a child that was interested both in
the nature World dreaming about the
Amazon rainforest and also my
grandfather was an inventor and it was
some kind of a model to me so I was
watching cassettes about Da Vinci and
other inventors and scientists of the
past
his background in tissue engineering
helped him develop a 3D printer that
recreates the taste texture and Aroma of
real meat it even reacts like meat on
the grill
microfilaments are ordered in a very
specific way so that it recreates the
structure and the function of an animal
muscle we move that the big machine is
and we are able to do that at scale at
hundreds of kilograms per hour
afterwards
[Music]
I remember when we tried the steak the
first time I was very worried that he
was working with the tough cuts and we
were working with just a prototype right
but he was very excited
foreign
[Music]
but then he gave us very interesting
inputs so that we could improve these
products very much
[Music]
I'm good
in my opinion is the most
straightforward way to save the planet
and this is my mission from now from
until I die
this unlikely pair might not share all
the same values but they are always
happy to share a meal
[Music]